we're back with America's mom Tabitha
Brown
um number one New York Times
best-selling author
with her book
s the soul
and now there's a follow-up Journal that
teaches us how to do just that you know
I'm opening a page Tabitha and I pointed
out to you like this paragraph starts
now honey
and then I was like how did you do that
and what did you say because I wrote it
in my voice that's how I talk so I want
people to feel like I'm talking to you
you know this is Deb trying to help you
along the way not tell you how to do it
but just encourage you as you do it for
yourself man ask what your advice is to
when you are writing something or
reading something or you know trying to
communicate in any way how you keep your
voice because your voice is so distinct
and it never gets Lost in Translation
any advice on how to have one's voice
not get lost in translation I think for
me because for so many years I I covered
my true voice and I conform trying to
make other people uh accept me or feel
comfortable the thing is about loving
yourself and realizing that wait a
minute my voice as it is who I am is
enough I deserve to be in this room in
this space and when you know that
without a shadow of a doubt you always
show up nobody can take your voice I
mean it's genuinely your superpower
it is
I've been your true self right can you
tell me and I know you've told it before
but I I really love the whole food story
like you were eating a sandwich
and you posted a video yeah I was
actually driving Uber you're an Uber
driver yep in 2017. I was driving Uber
and uh I had dropped somebody off by
Whole Foods I was very still new to
being vegan and so Whole Foods always
have a vegan option so I was like oh let
me go ahead and get me a little
breakfast put myself on a little break
and uh I went in there I had never heard
of vegan bacon before I got a sandwich
bacon right it was like a tempeh bacon
is the one that they had and so I ate
that first half I was like oh I need to
do a video Until people I found a new
Beacon option because that's what my
videos were about but want nobody
watching them and I sat in my car and
you know I told people I found this new
sandwich and how amazing it was to me
and by the time I got home the video had
like 50 000 views and I was like who
watching this video Lord and so the next
morning had over 100 some thousand I
told myself I said I think I'm going
viral and he was like well what does
that mean I said I don't know you know
um and then four days later the Whole
Foods reached out I was like we saw your
video we would love to work with you and
it has been uphill from there
yeah
can you play a game with us it's one of
my favorites it's called three to go it
just gives some Tabitha Brown
recommendations for us all to run with
okay all right this is three to go
[Applause]
all right Tabitha what's an Instagram
account that we should follow
um other than mine I will say no exactly
Eric Thomas Eric Thomas yes fantastic
next movie that can brighten any rainy
day I would say the Devil Wears Prada oh
my God it's the best
yes okay last the best response to give
someone when they are trying to bring
you down oh honey that ain't my business
and that's it that's what I tell them
that's not my business
[Laughter]
that's not my business thank you Tabitha
Brown for once again carrying us through
Tabitha's new book seen loved and heard
a guided journal for feeding the soul
the follow-up to her number one New York
Times bestseller feed the saw is out now
[Music]
foreign